intrinsic to liberalism is this idea
that you're constantly you have to be
liberating yourself from something
there's always got to be a bad guy
there's always got to be a boogeyman
oppressor that you're overcoming and the
problem for the left right now in
America is there just ain't that much
oppression it just ain't that much they
always talk about the white supremacists
the phantom white supremacists that are
constituting the majority of Americans
and they're so evil and terrible and
that's why we've got to stand up and
courageously say black lives matter even
though that's a statement that everybody
agrees with nobody disagrees with that
statement but we all have to pretend
like there's a huge number of people
here who disagree with that simple and
obvious statement and there just isn't
so for instance when the the allegedly
peaceful protests turned violent the
mainstream media told us well it it
turned violent because of the white
supremacists who showed up well you know
I'm looking at the footage I don't see a
lot of white supremacists all the big
threat here is the Ku Klux Klan the last
image I saw of the Ku Klux Klan was an
image from the Democratic governor of
Virginia's medical school yearbook okay
when he dressed up as a Klansmen for
Halloween or possibly in blackface we
still don't know which one he was in but
it was one of those the Ku Klux Klan how
many how many of them are there in the
country like four but the media has to
invent this phantom so that we can then
overcome it and expert extricate
ourselves from it you know we might be
able to celebrate in America that we
have a period of you know relative
justice equity prosperity Liberty you
know things are pretty good in this
country aren't they but that just
doesn't work and so the left invents the
Fantom they invent this phantom of
institutional oppression without
realizing the irony that they control
all of the institutions and it's only
going to get worse you see it's not that
I think some
squishes on the conservative side of
things they think that if we can just
prove to the left that no actually there
isn't that much oppression no actually
we aren't racist that then the left will
say okay good that's not how it works
the left is going to double down they're
gonna try to gin up racial tension even
more they're gonna try to divide people
even more they're gonna try to invent
even more racists and bigots because
they
need them to then overcome them they
need a villain and guess what buster no
matter how just a nice and wonderful and
and equitable you are and kind you've
got to be that villain if you oppose the
liberal left-wing agenda
[Music]
you
[Music]